so if you thought that the United States
had become a global laughingstock thanks
to Donald Trump before three days ago
then the u.s. is really doubly a
laughingstock right now the world is
literally laughing at the United States
because we have a dangerous fool as
president who is still supported by tens
of millions of Americans who recently
suggested we should look into injecting
bleach and isopropyl alcohol to treat
coronavirus here is the chief medical
officer in Australia Brendan Murphy
struggling if you're watching you'll see
him visibly struggling not to laugh as
he takes a question from the Australian
media about Donald Trump talking about
hitting the body internally with heat
light and disinfectants during
Thursday's White House coronavirus press
briefing last week professor today at a
briefing Donald Trump said that quote a
tremendous hit unquote of ultraviolet
light could see off the virus he also
referenced the effectiveness of
disinfectant and wondered whether
injections of disinfectant might also be
effective given that this is coming from
the president the United States an
influential person is there any
scientific basis to either of these
propositions I would not I would caution
against the injection of disinfection
there is they could be quite toxic to
people I'm not I wasn't privy to his
comments so I won't be very careful
about commenting on something that I
didn't hear myself certainly and
ultraviolet light I don't know the
context in which he said it so I really
would need to study it and to before I
could comment thank you if you watched
the clip you see the Australian chief
medical officer having difficulty to
avoid bursting out laughing because
that's what the world is currently doing
they're laughing at us and some also
just feel really bad for us I got a
number of nice messages over the weekend
including from friends of mine in other
countries Netherlands Italy other spots
from
family in Argentina from viewers in
Canada all who are essentially saying
we're really sorry for what you're
dealing with we're all dealing with the
virus but you were in addition to that
or dealing with Donald Trump here's the
the UK deputy chief medical officer also
asked about disinfectant injections now
Donald Trump being treated globally as a
vector of disinformation that must be
debunked time and again let's come back
one more thing many people in the UK
will have seen the clip overnight of the
President of the United States
suggesting coronavirus might be treated
by injecting disinfectant into the body
do you have a message to Donald Trump
about the dangers of spreading dangerous
disinformation when governments around
the world are trying to combat its
spread from other sources
here I'll defer to medical expertise
generally and so I wouldn't have a
specific message to Donald Trump I'd
have a specific message to anybody who
suggested they should be injecting
anything into their bodies I mean
clearly we would not support from a
medical professional perspective it is
really important that people use
appropriate treatments that are
evidence-based and tested we have very
good programs that have been taken up
very rapidly coordinated in this country
testing various different alternative
treatments those trials will report
reasonably early but certainly nobody
should be injecting anything and we
should be using evidence-based and
properly trialed treatments that we know
will be safe world disclaimers and
corporations like the makers of Lysol
having to clarify no don't even think
about doing this
here's Nicola Sturgeon the First
Minister of Scotland also having to
answer a similar question actually
saying what Trump said could be
dangerous responsibility on all leaders
right now there's always a
responsibility on leaders but it's
greater than ever during a crisis like
this and I have said it today I said it
yesterday I'm really keen that we have
an open discussion with the public and
the politicians unusually perhaps are
prepared to admit things they don't know
as well as share the thinking on the
that we do know we're not trying to work
through but the responsibilities and
leaders is not to stand up in a public
platform and repeat things that you have
perhaps half haired and perhaps
completely misunderstood and present
that to the public in a way that the
public might act on and that could be
dangerous and none of us are perfect
and we will all make mistakes in this
but I think we all have to remember that
very serious responsibilities when we're
giving advice to the public it must be
good advice informed by it by the best
science and as jason has just said it is
clearly not the case that ingesting
disinfectant in any way shape or form is
a good idea that is a very very bad idea
and extremely dangerous and there are
more from all around the world I won't
play them all for you today but this is
now what the world is dealing with we're
all dealing with the virus and the world
is having to come together corporate
America and foreign leaders all having
to come together to say when Trump
wondered aloud about injecting
disinfectants that was a bad idea don't
do it some of them are having trouble
not laughing when they're asked about it
you also by the way have poison control
centers receiving phone calls one
example is from Maryland the governor
Larry Hogan and Maryland is a Republican
he's no left-wing bomb thrower not a
Democrat said Trump was sending the
wrong message with the bleach fiasco and
that his state over the weekend received
hundreds of calls wondering if it is
safe to ingest cleaning products as a
result of Donald Trump's statement check
out the Republican governor here
explaining it many of your citizens
didn't see it as sarcasm is that how you
took it well look I think it's really
important this has been important to me
from day one
about communicating very clearly on the
facts because people listen to these
press conferences they listen when the
governor holds a press conference and
they certainly pay attention when the
president of the United States is
standing there giving a press conference
about something as serious as this
worldwide pandemic and that I think when
misinformation comes out or you just say
something that pops in your head it does
send a wrong message and we had hundreds
of
calls come in to our emergency hotline
at our health department asking if it
was if it was right to ingest Clorox or
you know alcohol cleaning products
whether that was going to help them
fight the virus so we had to put out
that warning to make sure that people
were not doing something like that which
would kill people actually to do it so
that's what happens when the guy who
thinks the Nobel Prize is the Nobel
Prize a Toby le it gets really bad and
it's gotten very very bad and again an
unforced error and we will see what
today's press briefing looks like after
all of this